hey what's up folks i'm international
master kostya kavutski
and today i'll be recapping the 2020 us
girls
junior chess championship so this year
the us championships is of course being
run completely differently
normally these tournaments are held in
person at the st louis chess club
but this year because of the pandemic of
course they are all being held online
which has actually been a blessing in
disguise because it means these
tournaments can run
back to back and all five of these
events the u.s girls junior the u.s
junior the u.s seniors the us women's
in the u.s championship are going to be
running back to back over the next
couple of weeks
here in october so the other thing
that's of course new and different about
these tournaments
is that they're using a rapid time
control 25 plus five
instead of of course the typical
classical control and to me that
makes me feel like the outsiders are
going to have more of a chance when it
comes to
these events because rapid chess and
especially online rapid chess
tends to be a little bit more volatile
so we're definitely in for some
really exciting action that said the
us girls junior was actually won by the
top seed karissa yep
who has actually now won this event for
three years in a row she won in 2018
and in 2019 and she made it a hat-trick
with her third victory
she scored seven and a half out of nine
points and
really really did uh amazing in this
tournament
second place went to international
master annie wang with
six out of nine and third place went to
rochelle wu with
five and a half points so in this video
i wanted to share some of the highlights
of the tournament some of the most
important and fantastic games and one of
the critical rounds actually took place
in round four when the two top seeds
were
facing off this was the top seed carissa
playing black against the number two
seed international master
annie wang and this was the first game
of the second day after day one annie
was actually leading the event with two
and a half out of three she started off
really strong
and was doing actually quite well in
this position as white
against carissa who was uh behind and
needed to win to overtake annie
in the standings and here black has a
pretty difficult uh position black is
down a pawn and the d5 pawn is isolated
and weak and
krista makes i think a very very
practical decision one that i think is
really instructive for most players out
there
especially for rapid chess she just
plays d4 just gives the pawn up
opens up the bishop because she
understands that this bishop
has to be unleashed and if black is
going to get any kind of play in this
position
it's going to be by opening up the
diagonal and hoping that she eventually
finds some tactics now andy of course
takes the pawn
rook the a display queen b3 bishop d5
queen v6
white is still of course completely
winning but at least now black has
some hope in the position uh and here
white plays bishop takes d4 which
i think the commentators immediately
singled out as being a little bit
unusual
uh knight takes d4 felt like the natural
choice and indeed white has a completely
winning advantage here now this move was
probably rejected by white because at
some point
black might play queen g3 and threaten a
lot of stuff around
her king instead she plays bishop takes
d4 and now after bishop c4
it's already a little bit murky for
whites even though the computer
still says white is totally winning here
it's already getting difficult and as
the time
takes down it just gets harder and
harder to play these uh positions
i think carissa really did a good job of
making the most out of her
practical chances in this tournament she
ended up winning a ton of games
here white plays g3 this ends up being a
very very serious mistake
this is a pawn move that they can't get
back and now the long diagonal was just
weakened for
the rest of the game it said something
like rook f2 and white was still doing
really well
but as you can see it was already kind
of an awkward position to play with just
so many
so many weaknesses in white's camp after
g3 queen e7
the players made some more moves and
black started reorganizing all the
pieces
on the diagonal and was already having a
really really strong initiative for the
two pawn
sacrifice eventually black's initiative
paid off and after rook c6
black grabbed the pawn rook c8 and now
karissa
goes for the long diagonal and these
light squares just absolutely kill white
and the game is already very very
difficult for white at this point
takes on c1 takes on b2 here bishop c4
was immediately winning the piece and
finishing the game
the players were of course in heavy time
trouble but uh chris just pulls the
bishop back
and this diagonal just ends up being too
painful for white
and she ended up winning this very very
critical game now once carissa grabbed
the lead in round four she basically
never let it go she just kept winning
lots and lots of games
and especially on her final day she won
all three of her games
uh starting with women's grandmaster
jennifer yu one of the
strongest players in the field and i was
really impressed by
this game because at this point carissa
is half a point ahead of the field this
is round seven
so this round and then two more rounds
to go and in this position
black plays a typical move g5 for this
kind of
rui lopez archangel type of position and
this move often gives white a choice
either play bishop g3
and play against black's kingside
weaknesses or just go for the immediate
sacrifice with knight takes g5 and play
for the king side attack
and despite being half a point ahead in
the standings and maybe wanting to play
it safe
chrissa just takes on g5 she felt like
it was
the strongest move in the position and
afterwards in the post game interview uh
carissa kind of explained it all and
said that basically it's easier to
attack in a rapid time control than it
is to
uh defend and that's kind of what
happens after hg bishop takes g5
i believe the best move and kind of only
move for black here is to go e takes d4
uh not just taking away the e3 square
from white's rook but also
introducing the idea of bringing in the
knight with knight e5 and of course
grabbing a pawn and
in the meantime and just trying to get
more pieces into the defense
in the game we saw king to g7 which
allows white to play rook to e3
and now white's attack is quite strong
although it was misplayed a little bit
by the players but of course this was a
rapid game so
uh they're obviously not going to be
playing perfectly in these sharp
situations
here white played rook g3 i think it was
better to first develop with knight to
d2 and then
bring the rook to g3 because here
jennifer finds really strong defensive
move bishop takes e4
not just grabbing an important central
pawn but finding a
chance to bring the bishop to g6 where
it can be a really good
defender after the move queen to d2
black ends up making a mistake with rook
to g8
best was bishop g6 just kind of sealing
the diagonal and
basically inviting white to give up the
dark square bishop for
black's rook on f8 something like takes
queen takes f8
and black would have two pieces for the
rook and be doing really really well
instead black played rook to g8 which
allowed white to take on f6
forcing king takes f6 and now after
queen h6 checked bishop g6 and knight d2
black's king is just kind of stuck out
in the open and white has a completely
winning attack here with so many pieces
ready to mate the king
charissa finished off really really
nicely here with d5 rook to e1
just bringing all the pieces into the
attack now on something like e4 white
can play
either knight takes e4 check with idea
queen f4 king to g7 and queen takes f7 a
very very nice
uh pin motif there uh leading to
checkmate on
the h file or white could also just play
i would say the simple rick takes e4
where flag goes d
takes e4 we have knight takes e4 uh
check and the king is going to get mated
very very soon after rookie 1 king e6
uh white's attack just started to
completely
flood in here rook to e8 was played
bishop takes d5
and chris finds a really nice tactic at
this moment after knight five nice
combination i should say
with the move rook takes f5 now the main
point is that if bishop takes f5 white
will have queen takes c6
uh checkmate just made in black's king
in the middle of the board
but the nicer point is that after rook
takes e3
trading rooks in between and bishop
takes f5
white still can take on c6 and is
winning the rook
in the corner and that was it white won
all of the material back
from the attack plus a couple of extra
pawns and
uh the game was just over and that was
really impressive to me that despite
being in a situation where any loss will
be devastating for her tournament
carissa still
decided to take the risk knowing it was
probably the right thing to do in the
position
and then adjust the fighter play with
strong attacking moves to
to back it up in the final game carissa
needed to defeat
one of her main rivals wim rochelle wu
and rochelle actually makes a mistake in
the opening plays this move bishop e6
and the night or
kind of at the wrong moment because now
white pounces with knight to g5
and immediately uh takes advantage of
black's last move
hitting the light squared bishop and
threatening in case of bishop c8
a very annoying and very powerful move
bishop c4 where black just won't have
any good way of defending the the light
squares
so black had to give up the light
squared bishop and chrissa finds a
pretty interesting way
of putting pressure on the light squares
with this a4
a5 advance followed up by this move rook
to a4 and
securing the c4 square for white's
bishop uh black had to play the
unfortunate king f7 here just to defend
the pawn
and now after the really strong move
queen a1 white has ideas of playing
queen a2 in every position
and really just hammering down on this
e6 weakness
i really like how white played this one
knight c5 takes takes
castles rook fd8 uh and now a really
useful move knight to e2
simply improving the knight and
preparing this f4 break
which would just allow white to break
through to black's position
the game did not last super long
black tried to hold on here but white's
pieces just started flying through
and then white found the nice tactic
here with knight to d5 hitting
both of black's pieces here and then
after knight takes d5
rook f7 check winning the queen on c7
takes takes knight e3 was played
bishop comes back to d5 b3 check getting
the queen in on the long diagonal
and then really nice simplification
tactic e5
allowing rook f1 check allowing black to
win back white's queen
but taking on d6 at the end and
transposing into a completely winning
endgame
where white's bishop has a lot of
targets to focus on
black's knight is hanging and of course
the d-pawn is a really really strong
past spawn uh the game did not last much
longer karissa grabbed a couple of pawns
brought the bishop back to d3 and here
black decided to resign as the apon is
going to be
way too strong for black to deal with in
the position and
that was just game over so chris have
finished with seven and a half out of
nine points a huge huge
performance uh like i mentioned uh annie
wang got a second place with
six out of nine um one of annie's best
games i would say
happened against uh wfm martha
samadashvili
uh in this position playing black annie
came up with a
really thematic uh sacrifice in this
kind of knighter structure
with the move d6 d5 really instructive
breakthrough
in the center uh just totally opening
things up for
black's position now the first point is
that if e takes d5 here
it seems like black doesn't really have
enough to capture the pawn
the idea was probably to go either
bishop to c5 or
bishop to b4 one of these moves and the
point is that black is going to be
taking on e3
winning back the d5 pawn and then having
a ton of pressure in the center and
on the c file for example something like
king h1
take on e3 queen takes e3 and now black
can
take on d5 either with the knight or
with the bishop we're going to play a
move like bishop f5 here and black has
just fantastic compensation and is going
to be winning back the pawn
very soon instead in the game white
decided to
play knights he takes d5 black took he
takes d5
bishop c5 c4 was played to hold on to
the extra d5 pawn
and here annie played e4 just
sacrificing a second pawn to open up her
pieces
uh and get some real initiative for her
material
now the point on f takes e4 was likely
to go queen f4
where black is ideas like knight g4 and
rookie 8 and bishop d6
and white's king side is basically way
too exposed here black has tons and tons
of compensation for
the two pawns i think white should have
still done this objectively instead
white played the move queen to e2
which anyway allows black to come in
with ef-3
rook t8 an 84 and now all of black's
pieces really become
super active attacking everything in
white's position queen e5 hitting the
rook
through it goes to b1 or a2 there's a
knight c3 fork in the position
uh white tried b4 here kind of a
desperate attempt uh knight g5 nice
response hitting the queen
keeping an eye on this rook and then
after naichi for white tried to make
some tactics work but
all the tactics were in black's favor
here as black's pieces were very active
rooks were connected
and after queen takes a1 bishop takes g5
and he found the pretty simple but still
very very satisfying x-ray background
trick with the rook t1
and leading to a forced checkmate so i
am annie wang also had a fantastic
performance
um but i gotta give shout out to i would
say the move of the tournament
uh hands down for anyone watching uh the
broadcast i think it had to have come
from this game uh it always takes two to
make a brilliant scene so here we have
uh wfm
sophie moore suzuki against wim talia
cervantes
and in this position uh sophie plays the
best move in the position castle's
queen side a really really sharp move
but white had to connect rooks and
develop the king
allowing black to grab on a2 but with
the idea of pushing
e5 and generating a ton of play using
this pin
objectively this was quite strong for
white but sophie unfortunately messes it
up
here it should have just taken on f6 and
then after hg
f takes g7 uh white would be getting the
better of things
instead we had a total mess after bishop
h4 95
uh check bishop takes d8 bishop e3 chat
king c2
queen a4 check the game just got
so so wild here now the first problem
for white is that on king to b1
uh black can play knight takes c3 check
b takes c3
and then queen b3 with at least a
perpetual
check it was clear that white was
playing for the win here so this was not
something
she wanted to allow instead she decides
to go king to d3
a very uh ambitious move but objectively
probably still
justified black played rook takes uh d8
and uh lining up against the king white
no fear goes bishop to e4
and surprisingly black actually doesn't
have such a great discovery against
white's king
because of course any night move is
going to undefend the bishop and allow
white to play king takes e3
instead talia goes queen to b5 check
white goes back king c2
queen a4 check and it seems like the
players are
repeating moves and objectively that is
what
should have happened here at this point
white cannot do better than in draw
so really should have just played king
d3 here and accepted the repetition
but uh sophie very boldly plays for the
win here with king to b1
just hoping for any final chance but
then this gives black a chance to
strike aliyah does play knight takes e3
b takes c3
and queen to b3 check now i believe the
commentators here
myself as well were kind of expecting
her to just make the repetition
uh both players were down to just
seconds here you know just no time on
their clocks uh
complete scramble you know five second
increments uh and the players did repeat
a little bit
after queen v3 chat king to a1 and then
out of nowhere comes the move rook to d2
a total shock to to me the commentators
everyone watching
the threat is made on the second rank
here with queen b2 or queen a2 and after
rook takes d2 bishop takes d2
even though black is only two pieces
left uh there's simply no good defense
to the threat of bishop takes c3
meaning white is just gonna have to give
up a queen for this bishop and is
totally lost uh something like rook to
c1
black can take the rook i can go queen
a3 check take the rook with check
and then is just completely winning here
um so
instead white played rook to d1 but
after takes
takes takes everything comes with check
all black needs to do is cover the back
rank with a5 and
the game was essentially over so a
really fantastic find by talia with rook
d2 especially
given that she had seconds on her clock
and was probably pretty happy with the
draw based on how the position was going
be a really really uh amazing find a
nice
nice display of courage when you're down
on time but you're still
trying to do everything you can to to
win the game
all right guys hopefully you enjoyed the
recap if you want to check out any of
the games i'll leave a link
to the leachat study below and you can
check them out
and stay tuned for the us junior
championship coming up starting on
tuesday october
13th uh that's going to be very very
exciting some of the best
juniors in america and as well as the
world that are going to be competing
and i'll be back for another recap at
the end of that tournament
so until then have a good one and take
care